thousands of hong kong residents queuing
up at testing centers across the city on
the day the territory records its
highest number of covert 19 cases since
the pandemic began
a record 614 infections were reported on
monday nearly double the number
announced the day before many of the
cases are untraceable
authorities called the sharp surge an
unprecedented challenge and urged people
to stay at home for people in hong kong
who lived for months without any local
transmission last year this is uncharted
territory i'm really worried not only
for myself but mostly for my
family and the other people around me
basically yeah it's been a crazy uh once
the year started you know no one
expected this
the government should be more scientific
or have a strategy and roadmap to let
the public understand the purpose of the
anti-epidemic measures
the government does not have any roadmap
or strategy now but only random plans
hong kong authorities have given no sign
they're willing to veer from the zero
covert 19 strategy adopted by mainland
china especially when vaccination rates
among hong kong's elderly remains
sluggish
strict pandemic controls are still in
place including flight bans and
quarantine facilities for those who test
positive hong kong is bracing for social
distancing restrictions to be extended
even further and officials warn that
cases here could rise in the coming days
as the effects of last week's lunar new
year gatherings take hold brick clinic
al jazeera hong kong